you didn't win the nobel prize the team
of bicep that led the bicep 2 didn't win
the nobel prize because of some
space dust that's right uh kick
uh
which one is the moon which one is that
one's the dust the space dust yeah
what are we looking at so why why is
space dust the
the villain of this whole story well
it's funny you know i wrote these books
and i don't know about you but when you
get all these books i'm sure you get
books people send you books they always
come in these dust jackets right i was
like what the hell is a dust jack like
how much dust is raining down at any
moment i mean this is immaculate this
room is russian tidiness galore but but
in a normal house how much dust is
raining down it's not not really pretty
until
i wrote a book and i realized you know
i'm writing a story about the origin of
the universe
and the prologue you know to the cosmos
and dust is going to cover this story it
was actually it's actually more a story
about
astrophysics and cosmology than dust and
this is the link between
the cosmological and the astrophysical
so what does that mean so astrophysics
is broadly speaking the study of
physical phenomena manifest in the
heavens astronomical phenomena
cosmology is concerned with the origin
evolution composition of the universe as
a whole but it's not really concerned
with stars galaxies and planets per se
other than how they might help us
measure the hubble constant the density
of the universe the neutrino content
etcetera etcetera
so we ten have a tendency to kind of
look a little bit you know they're like
not all astronomers and astrophysicists
are equal they're all equal but some are
more equal than others so we have kind
of a prejudice a little swagger right
and cosmologists are studying you know
we're using einstein we're not using
like you know boltzmann or we're
thinking of the biggest possible
pictures
in so doing you can actually
become blinded to otherwise obvious
effects that people you know would have
not overlooked in our case when we
sought out the signal we were using the
photons that make up this primordial
heat bath that surrounds the universe
luckily only at three degrees kelvin
approximately we're using those as a
type of film onto which gravitational
waves will reverberate it make them
oscillate preferentially in a polarized
way and then we can use our polarized
sunglasses but in a in a microwave
format to detect the characteristic
two-fold symmetry pattern under rotation
that's the technical way that we undergo
i mean there's a lot more to it
but there more than one thing that can
mimic exactly that signal first of all
when you look at the signal
the signal if inflation took place big
if but if it took place
the signal would be about one or two
parts per billion
of the cmb temperature itself
so a few nano kelvin the cmb is a few
kelvin the signal from these b modes
would be a few nanokelvin it's
astonishing to think pansies and wilson
1965 measured something that's a billion
times brighter and that was what 60
years ago let's call it 60 years ago
since they discovered it
moore's law you're more experts let's
call it every two years so you're
talking about like 2 to the 30th power
doubling or something like that at that
so let's call 2 to the 20th something
like that so that's like only um 2 to
the tenth is a as a as a thousand all
right correct my math i'm wrong to the
20th is a million right to the 30th is a
billion so you we're outpacing moore's
law
in terms of the sensitivity of our
instruments to detect these feeble
signals from the cosmos and they don't
have to deal with you know in the
semiconductor fabric factory in santa
clara california they have to deal with
like you know meteorites and nasty
things like coming into the laboratory
it's a clean room it's pristine they can
control everything about it right we
can't control the cosmos and the cosmos
is literally littered with particles of
schmutz of failed planets asteroids
meteoroids things that didn't coalesce
to make either the earth the moon the
planet jupiter or its moons or get
sucked into them and make craters on
them et cetera et cetera the rest of it
is falling and it comes in a power
spectrum there's very few thank god
chicks a love size you know impact uh or
you know progenitors that will take out
all life on earth
but there's extremely large number of
tiny dust particles and microscopic
grains and then there's a fair number of
intermediate sized particles
it turns out this little guy here
is um
is the end product of a collapsing star
that explodes in what's called a
supernova type 2 supernova so stars
spend most of their life using helium
nuclei protons into um
and neutrons into helium
nuclei and then from there it can make
other things like beryllium and briefly
make beryllium and carbon nitrogen
oxygen all the way up until it tries to
make iron
and nickel
iron and nickel are endothermic it takes
more energy than gets liberated to make
an atom of iron when that happens
there's no longer enough heat supplying
pressure to resist the gravitational
collapse of the material that was
produced earlier so the star forms goes
inside out that's how
scientists discovered helium was
discovered on the sun i don't know did
you know that's why it's called helium
yeah they went there at night and
oh well done they went there at night no
helium means helios is the god of the
sun it was discovered in its spectrum
from observations of the telescope like
150 years ago it wasn't discovered like
when uh oxygen and you know iron was
discovered um so it's only a relatively
recent comer to the pure activity the
helium came after oxygen oh no first
first hydrogen forms into helium so
that's the first thing that forms now in
terms of discoveries oh yeah after
oxygen yeah i think priestly and
yeah and others the dalton discovered it
in the 1700s no helium was really only
discovered from the spectrum of looking
at the sun and seeing the weird atomic
absorption and
called fraunhofer lines in the solar
spectrum
so but when it tries to make iron
there's no longer any leftover heat in
other words there's heat left over from
fusing as you know the sun of a plasma
physics if you use to
hydrogen nuclei you get excess energy
plus you get helium so that's why fusion
energy could be the energy source of the
future and always will be no no
hopefully it'll come much sooner than
that and so doing trying to make iron it
takes more energy doesn't give off
enough energy star collapses explodes
and what does it spray out into the you
know cosmic interstellar medium it
sprays out the last thing it made which
is that stuff luckily for us because
some of that coalesced and made the core
of the earth onto which the lighter like
silica and carbon and the dirt and the
crust of the earth were formed and some
of that made its way to the crust the
iron made its way to the crust some of
that your mother ate and uh synthesized
hemoglobin molecules and hemoglobin has
iron particles and it's a quite amazing
substance without it you know we
wouldn't have a red blood we wouldn't
exist
uh as we are
is this a very long complicated mom joke
i've done enough dad jokes my quote is
up um so i'm taking this this object uh
you know seriously there's not all of it
gets bound up in a planet in fact
forming planets is very inefficient um
and so there's a lot of schmutz left
over some of which gets in the way
of our telescopes looking back to the
beginning of time and some of those
molecules like iron is used in compass
needles right they're magnetized and
magnetic fields in our galaxy can align
them and make the exact polarization
pattern that we're looking for as if the
compass needles get all aligned that's
like the polarization of of the dust
grain it's like that felt polarizing
filter that means light polarized like
this will get absorbed
and light polarized like this will go
through so it's absorbing it's making
100 polarized light out of an initially
unpolarized light source and that's what
happened and what we ended up claiming
we on on march 17th
and i'm sure if you were there you might
remember this at the harvard center for
astrophysics there was an announcement
there were like three or four nobel
prize winners in the audience and the
bicep2 team which i was no longer
leading i was still a member of it in
fact in the announcement the first
person they mentioned
besides you know thank you all for being
here is me and my team at uc san diego
although i wasn't invited to go to the
press conference uh because that uh
harvard complicated yes exactly um it's
a little school up there in the in
cambridge area um and so uh they ended
up making this announcement that we
discovered the aftershocks of inflation
we detected the gravitational waves
shaking up the cmb and on that day past
lex friedman podcast back when it was
called artificial intelligence max tag
mark said goodbye
universe hello multiverse and hello
nobel prize
see he saw that as confirmatory evidence
not only of inflation not only
gravitational waves but of the
multiverse goodbye universe hello
multiverse uh multiverse is a natural
consequence consequence of inflation yes
according to its prominent you know
supporters yeah uh yeah and of course
leave the poetry to max which uh he does
masterfully
okay
so that the excitement was there i mean
maybe
the initial heartbreak for you is there
too that's that's some of the darker
moments you're going through but broadly
for the space of science
there's excitement there
and and i often note that this is a
problem in what i call you know the
science media complex because oftentimes
you'll see things like past guest sarah
seeger
venus life you know exists and that will
be really i mean it's fascinating right
and with the work that she's doing or
her colleagues are doing uh or clara
who's on your show as well and
that will be on front page new york
times boston globe san diego union
tribune it'll be above the fold
make headlines around the world and then
six months 12 months later as a case for
us retraction page c17 of the saturday
edition that nobody reads you know and
underneath the personal so we have a
problem in science that the you know if
it if it uh if it explodes it leads you
know and we get this huge fanfare and
this is not unique to my experiment this
happened with the earlier discovery of
so-called
martian life uh discovered in antarctica
um which was announced after peer review
we weren't peer reviewed at the point
where we made the announcement we had a
press conference and there are other
reasons that the team leaders felt it
was important to do that so that we
don't get scooped by a referee who's
unethical we thought we had done
everything right but that's confirmation
there's like levels to this yeah there
were many levels and there were people
you know me warning about how it would
be interpreted and wanting to also make
sure that we put all the data out
including the maps which we still
haven't released and um so there were a
lot of reasons to be skeptical but the
audi the
the public never knows this yeah i think
it's so i've made a rule that if i am
ever in charge of you know doling out
large amounts of science funding that
when you you should keep kind of an
option in other words you should have
money for publicity it's fine have money
for your press conference but hold in
reserve in a bond to be used hopefully
never but if it's to be used an equal
fund for the retraction
if it should occur
so you would like to see um because
that's a big part of transparency is the
is the
to me in the space of science at least
that's as beautiful
because it reveals
the
it's like it's uh it tells a great story
there's a there's an excitement there's
uh
there so there's a climax of the triumph
but there's also climax to the like the
disappointment yeah yeah because that
also eventually leads
to triumph again that sets up that's the
drama that sets up the triumph like with
andrew wiles bringing for mars
uh from us theorem as i guess it's not
lasting or whatever the
is
like that the ups and downs of that the
roller coaster the whole thing should be
is science that is science and when we
don't do that then we cultivate this
aura that excludes other scientists
often from minorities or women back that
you have to be eins like einstein came
out of the womb and he was just like
this guy was like curly no he wasn't he
was he wasn't bad at math that was all
that's all nonsense but he said that he
you know when he said he attributed his
success to lex he said i never asked my
dad
what happened when i ran alongside a
light beam as a kid and thank god i
didn't because had i he would have told
me the best answer of the day which by
the way you know he would create 20
years later as a 26 year old in in the
patent office obviously in switzerland
and in so doing by delaying when he
asked these questions he said i
approached it with the intellect of a
mature scientist not a little kid and i
wouldn't have accepted the same
explanation so sometimes assuming that
scientists are infallible inevitable uh
omniscient you know being i think that
really does a disservice jim gates said
you know he's like einstein wasn't
always einstein and we cultivate this
mystery and allure at our peril because
we're humans until we have artificial
einstein which i don't think will ever
exist
you